Jennifer Czech was most likely born in
1992 I noticed the movie theater Marquee
in her town is showing baby mama and
Forgetting Sarah Marshall both of which
came out in April 2008 and the script
states that Jennifer is 16 years old
Jennifer grew up in a small town of just
7,000 known as Devil's Kettle Minnesota
where she met her lifelong best friend
Anita Les Nikki who became known as
needi for short due to her attachment to
her more popular and outgoing friend
from the very beginning Jennifer is in
charge of the relationship getting the
better Barbies in the sandbox as kids
stealing Anita's toys pouring lemonade
on Anita's bed mocking her for being
scared of a boom box at Girl Scout camp
and eventually calling all the shots in
the friendship as teenagers still they
remain attached as evidenced by their
matching BFF necklaces that's why we're
biffs though n's feelings for Jennifer
seemed to go beyond that at one point
they got blitzed on Peach schnaps and
Jennifer became her first kiss she
claims that they're not lipstick Lesbos
as she puts it in Jennifer's case she
seems to be bisexual but she leans more
towards being interested in men while
Jennifer was always a cruel friend the
onset of puberty really seems to magnify
her behavior and although needy may not
realize it yet the reason Jennifer acts
the way she does is out of insecurity
she does a number of things to cover
this up like hooking up with Eric Bogart
at summer camp losing her virginity in
junior high taking laxatives to stay
skinny spitting a lot of profanity and
wearing a mask of insincerity to hide
the fact that she cares what people
think about her I mean her vanity is
filled with pictures of herself it's
possible that some or most of this
insecurity comes from being abandoned by
her father all of the behaviors that I
just listed are prime examples of what
the modern internet would probably refer
to as fatherless behavior and while this
is just a meme term used to stereotype
people it does come from a real place
there is actual research to suggest that
teenage girls with an absent Father
Figure are twice as likely to be
promiscuous and act out the idea is that
girls who grew up without a father will
seek male attention to fill that void
there's not a lot of focus on this but
it feels deliberate that Jennifer's
father is never mentioned and her mom is
single my mom has a date with that guy
who own the hamst in 2006 Jen was the
snowflake Queen we never find out what
that is I'm assuming it's either a part
in a school play or an honor given out
at a winter themed school dance but it's
clear that it's yet another cover of
Jennifer's insecurity how could I ever
be insecure I was the snowflake Queen in
high school Jen became a flag twirler on
Color Guard where she's featured front
and center in the performances the
perfect spot to get attention from boys
but at the end of the day an insecure
teenager who spends her time watching
Fitness videos browsing Myspace and
listening to Fallout Boy in 2008 is not
that out of the ordinary but Jennifer's
ordinary life became anything but on one
February evening when an indie rock band
she was fawning over tried to sacrifice
her to Satan at the base of a waterfall
while singing a two tone song to learn
the meaning behind the often
misunderstood Oddities of Jennifer's
Body the extra details only seen in the
comic how the character relates to the
true story experienced by the
screenwriter and the secret that big
farmer doesn't want you to know about
PMS then stick around to the end of this
video this video is sponsored by
[Music]
Factor Saint tube p s of online video
please give me the power to crush this
bit welcome to Horror history Jennifer's
Body is the Unapologetic emo 2009 comedy
horror film about a high school succubus
in the midwest it was directed by Karen
kusama and written by Diablo Cody with a
first name like Diablo you know she's
either an interesting artist type or a
stripper turns out it's both an Ur is a
filmmaker whose personal influence and
artistic control over a movie are so
great that the filmmaker is considered
the author this is usually a term used
to refer to the director but Diablo is
an excellent example of an Ur
screenwriter for example Minnesota is a
place that's important to her because
that's where she came out of her shell
and her first three feature film credit
Juno Jennifer's Body and young adults
are all set in Minnesota to reflect that
period in her life I bring this up
because there's definitely a huge piece
of Diablo in the character Jennifer cat
which I will be talking about but first
as I was researching her for my script I
came to the realization that Diablo Cody
is like a mirror image of me minus her
stripper Saga and the divorces for one
she's a huge horror movie fan after she
won the Oscar for her first script Juno
she basically had free reign to do
whatever she wanted and she didn't
hesitate to choose horror my entire life
had dreamed of writing a horror movie
I'm a huge horror fan she also ghost
wrote the 2013 Evil Dead and wrote the
upcoming Lisa Frankenstein besides her
love of horror and being a writer she
also seems to be interested in emo which
is very evident in the movie we
definitely knew we wanted a rock sound
kind of a punk sound I don't know if you
noticed the screeching wizel is in the
movie that's one of my favorite bands oh
great and then of course you guys and
Paramore and she's apparently a huge
roller coaster Enthusiast I'm super
super super obsessed with roller
coasters I've traveled all over I've
written hundreds of roller coasters
anyone who has seen my Final Destination
3 video or seen me in the comment
section of every roller coaster YouTuber
or just anyone who follows me on
Instagram knows that coasters are one of
my top four main passions and on top of
all that she's from Chicago but Diablo
knew that her horror movie was going to
be unlike any other to understand her
Central character let's take it back to
the tragic day that changed
everything it must have been a warm
winter in Minnesota because it doesn't
look all that cold on the day that
Jennifer makes plans for herself and
needy to go see the band A Low Shoulder
at a local bar in February 2008 2 months
before the spring formal just 2 months
ago me Jennifer and my boyfriend Chip
were completely normal people Jennifer
wants to see L shoulder because she
likes the singer I saw their Myspace
page and the lead singer extra salty
plus there'll be lots of other salty
morsels there for you it's interesting
that she uses terms like salty and
morsels to describe attractive guys both
words you would typically use to
describe food it makes a metaphor that
you probably already figured out even
more clear when she eventually goes on a
cannibalistic Rampage it's an allegory
for sleeping around as they get ready to
go we see just how little respect
Jennifer has for her supposed friend she
controls her wardrobe talks down to her
boyfriend's chip and even physically
pushes her against a door when they
arrive at Melody Lane her true fatal
flaw comes out in both a figurative
sense and a literal
one you don't have to be a succubus to
take advantage of fresh nutritious meals
that'll boost your energy and leave you
feeling great for humans I recommend
fact factor is the ready to eat meal
delivery service that lets you skip the
grocery store prep work and cooking
fatigue you don't even have to seduce
your meals to a remote location to
devour them in secret just jump on the
app choose what you want to eat and they
will send them right to your front door
in addition to their delicious lunch and
dinner options Factor now offers
breakfast smoothies juices and small
bites to power you up and crush your New
Year's goals it's easy to fall into the
Trap of ordering takeout or delivery
when you're busy but factor is cheaper
tastes better in my opinion is faster
because you heat it for just 2 minutes
and yet it still comes out tasting
fresher than a meal that's been trans
reported from a restaurant I've been
enjoying factor for a year now and
honestly just no complains I am
energized and ready to crush YouTube
with some fire content in 2024 oh look
it's time for you to get Factor head to
factor75.com or click the link below and
use code cz50 to get 50% off your first
Factor box and free wellness shots for
Life two free wellness shots from three
available flavors for every order while
you're an active subscriber that's code
cz50 or click the link below for this
lifechanging
deal
whether it's due to lack of a father
figure a boredom with Suburban life or
some other hidden factor it's clear that
Jennifer is trying to grow up too fast
as soon as they get there she's talking
about how she can't wait until she's old
enough to get wasted comments on all the
guys she'd like to get with and briefly
demonstrates that she's already in an
inappropriate relationship with a police
kid at who's probably in his early 20s
oh don't do
that okay not here funny how Chris Pratt
went from policing the smallest town
ever to policing the whole dang Galaxy
Jennifer acts confident in front of her
friends claiming that her boobs are like
smart bombs that give her all the power
over boys but in practice her
insecurities surface and she's actually
a super awkward flirt you play her
instruments really super good she offers
to buy the front man Nikolai a drink
confident that she'll be able to
convince the bartender to serve her
because of her tits and this actually
works no problem but this quickly proves
that she doesn't have the power over
Nikolai he has the power over her during
his performance they make quite a bit of
eye contact and she looks transfixed
almost hypnotized by his per performance
when the band's amplifier shorts out and
starts a huge fire she hardly seems to
notice until needy pulls her away to
safety outside the venue Nikolai finds
them and invites them into his van for
safety it's one of the strangest scenes
you'll ever see needi is traumatized
Jennifer is still Spellbound but Nikolai
is casually drinking a beverage as
people are being cooked alive in the
building behind them he gives Jen a sip
of his drink claiming it'll bring her
out of shock then he pulls her along to
the van as needy tries to convince her
to come back to town and get nachos at
their favorite spot Jennifer is being
presented with a symbolic Choice she a
16-year-old caught right on the line
between childhood and adulthood going
back to needy represents safety going
back to the suburbs with her childhood
friend and predictability while going on
with Nikolai and the band from the big
city represents alcohol sex and danger
all things that she Associates with
growing up because she's so hypnotized
by Nikolai she chooses to go into the
van with him it's only after they drive
off and she sees occult objects in books
that she realizes she's in over her head
and starts to freak out when she hears
one of the band members ask Nikolai if
he's sure that she's a virgin she lies
thinking she'll convince them not to try
anything with her I'm a virgin I've
never I've never even done sex I don't
know how so you guys should find
somebody who does she doesn't realize it
yet but that's not what they're
interested in the band has plans to
sacrifice a virgin to Satan under the
waxing moon and exchange for legendary
rock and roll Fang I've watched the
whole sequence with the fire and the
departure from the venue multiple times
trying to figure out if starting the
fire was also part of the plan or part
of the ritual it appears to just be a
random electrical fire however Nikolai
acts so casually about it it makes me
think that the demon may have played a
part in starting it in order to give
them a reason to take a young girl away
in their van there's also the fact that
earlier on needy can be seen playing
these pinball machines fire and getaway
almost like they're predicting what's
about to happen as if a higher power has
dictated their Destiny also the first
thing that's likely to come to your mind
when Jennifer gets into their van is
that she's about to be a victim of
something else that she may be coerced
into becoming an underage grouping this
is obviously a Trope in the world of
touring musicians from the early days of
rock and roll that has persisted until
the present there's a whole whole Tik
Tok trend of girls sharing outfits to
try to get noticed by an artist at a
concert a lot of that is probably
delusion but as I said earlier
stereotypes do often come from somewhere
and sadly there are cases where the
adult musicians take advantage of
unwavering fandom from their young fans
Low Shoulder sacrifice of Jennifer is
very much an allegory for that type of
behavior and this is briefly confirmed
by Diablo Cody in an interview is
dealing with themes of like consent
assault Abus of power and this can be
seen in the way that they tie her down
and the knife represents is a hot murder
weapon yeah I think you get the idea but
the entire ritual hinges on the idea
that Jennifer is actually a virgin which
as we know she is not according to the
books in the occult section at Devil's
Kettle High Library the ritual can still
be performed but may result in something
known as demonic transference if the
human sacrifice is impure the result may
still be attained but the demon will
forever reside in the soul of the victim
she must forever feed on flesh to
sustain the demon the text goes on to
elaborate we don't see the entire page
at any point but by combining multiple
shots I was able to piece together most
of it most of it's not that interesting
but there are a couple of things that I
want to highlight the Romans believe
that some deities transferred to animals
this is why many sculptures of animals
can be found near all Roman
archaeological sites we'll come back to
that but the result of The Botch ritual
is that Jennifer is turned into a
succubus there is surprisingly few
examples of succubi appearing in movies
so I did some research paranormal
research traditionally a succubus is a
demon that appears in a female form who
seduces men in their sleep to steal
their souls or in some cases of the
mythology steal their semen in order to
create evil children with the powers of
Witchcraft the idea first started
appearing in folklore around the
medieval period it may have been a
legend created to try to explain the
phenomenon of wet dreams or even sleep
paralysis Jennifer's Body has a unique
spin on the legend wherein the succubus
eats males as a means of satiating the
Demon's hunger and giving it power the
library books mention flesh eating and
racious feeding the demon becomes weaker
as it gets hungry and eating flesh will
Revitalize her power so although she
should have been killed by the knife
wounds she survived due to demonic
transference and woke up alone not able
to remember anything going back back to
our Rock And Roll tour bus metaphor this
represents the idea of her getting
roofied and blocking out in this case
her supernatural abilities are an
allegory for changes experien during
puberty that's why she's seducing and
eating boys and her strange Behavior
could be explained as puberty induced
mood swings for example she wanders back
to need's house and sneaks into her
kitchen she's totally silent only
flashing her friend a red smile before
pulling a rotisserie chicken out of the
fridge and eating it off the ground she
would later explain that she was hungry
but didn't want to kill her best friend
so she went for the chicken instead
always a good choice but her new demonic
sensibilities seem to reject
it and she ends up projectile vomiting
this black spiky sludge it seems to be
her body's way of rejecting normal human
food and telling her that she won't be
able to sustain herself with anything
other than human flesh she starts
laughing like a maniac when she realizes
this it's not a happy laugh it's more of
a weird coping thing she's taken
advantage of needy her entire life and
now she's ironically going to have to
eat her so she pins her friend to the
wall and begins to bite her neck but in
the end she can't bring herself to do it
and disappears into the NS as she
wandered back home she encountered AMT
an Indian exchange student that she had
been eyeing earlier he becomes her first
victim when she takes him into the woods
and devours him to restore some of the
Demon's power it's clear that she
doesn't yet realize that she's become a
succubus she just sees her new impulses
As Natural changes the next day the fire
at Melody Lane and the 47 lives lost is
the talk of the school but Jennifer
shows up with a new lease on
life
at school in the morning nidi is
surprised to see Jennifer looking
completely normal and she plays off the
bizarre events of the previous night as
NY overreacting again she's also
completely unfaced to learn about the
people who died in the fire even after
finding out the casualties included
eight students and a teacher sucks to be
them I guess Jennifer is back to being
her usual toxic self but she kind of
takes it to a new level that makes her
seem straight up sociopathic while the
rest of the community is in shambles
after school she approaches the School
football captain Jonas coelle who is
really emotionally distraught on the
surface it looks like he's upset about
losing his best friend Craig in the fire
however Jenifer and a select few others
know that just one day earlier Jonas was
in a fight with Craig over a girl so the
emotions he's feeling are really rooted
in self-pity and low self-esteem this
makes it easy for her to manipulate him
she takes him to a spot in the woods
that's popular for hookups telling him
it's what Craig would have wanted they
find themselves surrounded by a huge
assortment of wild animals this is
probably one of the strangest Mysteries
surrounding Jennifer this could be
connected to the text in the demonology
books from the library claiming that
Romans believe that sometimes demonic
transference would transfer the entity
into animals leading them to create
Grand animal sculptures another idea I
had is that this is supposed to be like
a fairy tale moment like the animals in
Snow White basically to create the idea
that everything is going to be okay for
Jonas things are going to get better now
that he and Jennifer are together when
in reality they're just lining up for
his leftovers after what happens next
Jennifer slams him into a tree and
transforms into the flesh ripping form
of the succubus where she proceeds to
Chow Down and devour his insides finally
replenishing her and relieving the
Demon's hunger to clean the Carnage off
of herself she jumps in the lake and
goes for a swim when she gets out you
can see the steam coming off of her that
night she tells needi that she's feeling
better than ever and she famously Burns
her tongue with the lighter and watches
it heal immediately she even calls
herself a God and starts asking about
need's boyfriend as if she's interested
devouring Jonas seems to give her a huge
boost and she appears to be the only
happy person in the school though she at
least seems to keep a low enough profile
for Jonas's funeral earlier I mentioned
that Jen's cannibalistic Grand page is
actually a metaphor for her sleeping
around we know that she has insecurity
problems so it's obvious that she's
using these encounters to boost her
self-esteem in a literal sense her
health is improving because the
consumption of human flesh gives the
demon power to sustain her but what this
really represents is her going to bed
with someone to boost her ego feeling
the emotional high that comes with that
for a little while then sinking back
into being miserable again if she
doesn't keep feeding the Demon's hunger
will always return this is a temporary
solution that never addresses the root
of the issue shortly after Jennifer gets
paired up with local Green Day influen
see Colin Gray in science class and
although it's awkward at first they bond
over their love of the punk rock band of
the dwarves and eventually become
friends at least in Colin's eyes
Jennifer doesn't seem to have any
respect for him outside of class
meanwhile the band Low Shoulder gains
National radio recognition and they're
celebrated as the heroes of the Melody
Lane tragedy their song Through the
Trees is sung at a candlelight vigil for
the victims and it becomes the town's
unofficial Anthem over the course of the
next month I have to imagine that this
really agitated Jennifer because not
only does she know firsthand that
they're evil but they literally tried to
sacrifice her and exchange for their fan
when she finds out that they'll be
releasing a benefit single for the
victim she comments on how she thinks
the production is poor she also tells
needy that she's not feeling great which
leads to my favorite line of hers are
you PMSing or something PMS isn't real
needy it was invented by the boy run
media to make us seem crazy she also
makes an off-hand comment about how it
must be wearing off it's been a month
since she turned Jonas into an after
school snack so the Demonic benefits are
starting to dissipate but despite
looking like what she refers to as one
of the normal girls she's still
garnering a attention from her male
classmates and Colin invites her to a
showing of Rocky Horror which she
initially turns down because she quote
doesn't like boxing movies Colin is so
dumbfounded by this comment that he just
gives up and walks away which is 100%
the right response it's not until needi
mentions that she actually thinks Colin
is really cool that Jennifer changes her
mind and invites him over to her place
this just shows her insecurity peeking
through again she's literally not
interested in him until she realizes she
can use him as a means of dominating
needy however the address that she gives
him is not her house it's a construction
site she's decorated an upstairs room
with candle lights and a blanket and
leaves some music playing waiting for
him to arrive and when he does she tries
to get down to it immediately we see a
pack of rats run in their Direction
similar to how her encounter with Jonas
attracted some wild animals a month
earlier her eyes suddenly go yellow and
she backs him into a sharp tool o
puncture wound God that's so emo that
was totally uncalled for she twists and
snaps his forearm and as she finishes
him off that is finishes killing him the
last thing he hears is this phrase I
need you frightened I need you hopeless
and while all this is going on it's
intercut with needi who is with her
boyfriend at the time and she
inexplicably starts repeating the word
hopeless as she sees visions of
Jennifer's victims for the sake of time
I'm not going to speculate on this
unless I do a needy episode in the
future but I bring it up because the
word hopeless becomes a theme between
the two basically part of their
relationship involves Jennifer keeping
her best friend under her thumb by
constantly knocking her down in order to
raise herself up my speculation is that
when she says I need you hopeless that's
really Direct at needy who's the reason
that she invited Colin over in the first
place anyway after growing out her Fang
she tears Colin apart with them then
crouches down and slurps up his blood
after this she crosses through the woods
and climbs out into the street where
she's nearly hit by need's car needi
manages to avoid the Collision but
Jennifer jumps on her windshield
cracking it and flashes a bloody smile
she most likely wants to intimidate NY
and basically continue to dominate her
so she sneaks into her house and waits
for her in her bed this not only
demonstrates that Jennifer knows about
need's feelings towards her but she's
also willing to manipulate them in order
to have control over her
hi NY screams at her to get out but she
just kind of downplays it reminding her
that they used to share a bed together
during slumber parties she tries to calm
her down by playing with her hair and it
leads to something a little bit more
intimate we know this isn't their first
kiss but based on need's reaction I'm
guessing it may be their second and the
chemistry cannot be understated you know
the YouTube channel movie clips the
channel That Just posts clips from
pretty much every movie they posted five
clips from Jennifer's Body but this
kissing scene is by far the most popular
at the time of writing this it has 419
million views making it the fourth most
watched movie clip of all time the
comment section just kind of says it all
special thanks to Megan Fox and Amanda
Cipher for making my teenage years 10
times more complicated with this scene
this scene is amazing you can see how
needi is slowly seduced by Jennifer and
how she gives in to some hidden desire
she had my hormone crazy teen self took
5 hours to finish this movie uh you know
what I I think we can stop reading the
comments the point is that this scene
really stuck with people but this
intimate encounter would not be the only
reason their friendship would be forever
[Music]
changed when nidi finally breaks out of
the trance that Jennifer has her in and
realizes how weird all this is she
threatens to call the police over the
Gory incident that she saw Jennifer in
shortly beforehand but she's reminded
that Jennifer is sleeping with a Cadet
which she believes will give her
immunity she decides to finally explain
everything that happened on the to the
fire the satanic Indie band The
attempted sacrifice
8675309 eating a met and her Newfound
Powers when she's full she can't be
killed and any wounds heal instantly
when needi starts to ask too many
questions which start to sound like
accusations Jen suggests that maybe she
should talk to a shrink about her
disturbing thoughts basically implying
that these are all need's ideas and
she's not planning on admitting to any
wrongdoing when asked to leave again she
jumps out the top floor window and
disappears into the night another month
passes by and without having eaten any
new boys Jennifer's physical condition
worsens again meanwhile the newest worry
in town has become this cannibal serial
killer targeting teenage boys ladies
pepper spray there's obviously a sicko
out there who likes boys and I think
this kind of ties back into the
violation SL assault themes that I
talked about during the ritual scene
Jennifer had this horrible thing happen
to her and it turned her into this
monster now she's turning the
traditional safety procedures on their
head and it's the boys who have to arm
themselves with self-defense tactics
usually reserved for women this is where
need's Research into the occult
convinces her that Jennifer's planning
to make a F out of the Devil's Kettle
high spring formal dance which would
take place on April 18th 2008 Jennifer's
evil I know no I mean she's actually
evil not high school evil L shoulder is
taking a night off their national tour
to play the smalltown school dance which
to me feels like a reference to Fallout
Boys music video dance dance where they
play A Homecoming dance so I guess still
going to be like this for guys like us
no way man one I could change it all all
right ladies break it up what do you you
looking at Powerpuff Fallout Boy owns
their own record label called de Cadence
and many of their artists are featured
on the Jennifer's Body soundtrack which
is fire not to mentioned the Fallout Boy
poster scene in Jennifer's room however
Jennifer doesn't go to the dance instead
she intercepts chip in the park he
usually cuts through to get to the
school using some kind of teleportation
or super speed ability to sneak up ahead
of him when he looks
back she attempts to give chip an
explanation for need's pulling away from
the relationship as of late telling him
that she was upset because her and Colin
were intimate she doesn't mince words
and by that I mean they were poring on a
semi-regular basis this is another Ultra
toxic attempt for her to get between
needi and CHF the real reason needi is
pulling away is because she knows
Jennifer is dangerous if she killed
Colin Gray just out of jealousy because
needi said he was cool what is she going
to do to the boy that needi actually has
a relationship with there's an important
detail in the comic that I think tells
us a lot about Jennifer's Behavior needy
less Nikki is my very best friend
Jennifer may be more popular and get
more attention from boys but nothing
that happens in her dating life ever
amounts to a relationship we' never see
anything resembling another meaningful
friendship even as much as she would
never admit it she's jealous of what
needi has with chip and insecure about
becoming less important in the eyes of
her only friend so she sabotages needi
and Chip's relationship and when the
distance between them is at its greatest
she tries to move in on chip telling him
that she's always cared about him and
that needi never deserved him in the
first place it's clear that this is more
about needy than it is about chip when
she says this say it like you mean it
say I'm better the media they relocate
to an abandoned pool where the word
hopeless is graffitied above the water
the same word that comes up time and
time again in connection to Jennifer
trying to socially isolate her friend
the artwork on the wall also makes it
look like they're coming out of a Roman
Temple which could be connected to the
information about the shrines to demonic
transference at Roman archaeological
sites seen in the occultism books in the
library it could also be connected to
the police cadet that Jennifer's
sleeping with whose name is Roman
Jennifer tries to kiss chip again but
this time he pulls away telling her that
it feels weird this sends her into a
rage she throws him into the pool and
thrashes him around leaving him unable
to escape after digging her fangs into
his neck nidi shows up and let's just
say spoils the
moment s causes please give me the power
to crush this and there's that word
again hopeless needi pulls her under the
water surface and she disappears
momentarily before reemerging and
immediately getting maced in the face
with chips pepper spray this causes her
to projectile vomit that black substance
that we saw earlier when she attempted
to eat the chicken after this she stops
holding back levitating out of the pool
and floating in midair it's here that
the root of the tension that's been
bubbling for Jennifer in need's entire
lives is finally
addressed a lifetime of frustrations
from the relationship comes pouring out
as needy calls Jen out for being a bad
friend chastises her for going after
chip when she according to needy could
have anyone and exposes her insecurities
about her looks and social relevance
it's clear that needi has never stood up
to her like this before and it sends
Jennifer into an absolute rage I am
going to eat your soul and Sh it out
Nikki thought you only murder boys I go
both ways but she's stopped in her
tracks when chip impels her with a pool
nut which ironically is the second time
we've seen that on my channel lately
since she hasn't had a meal in about a
month she doesn't regenerate right away
so she climbs out of the pool house and
Escapes in the comic she cuts through a
graveyard to get home and she's once
again followed by an assorted pack of
wild animals her condition continues to
worsen as she returns home to Circle
boys in the yearbook but in this case
instead of circling boys that she wants
to go out with she's circling the ones
that she wants to Devour the salty ones
as she would probably put it as she's
about to drift to sleep nidi breaks in
through her window and a fight to the
death ensues like the sacrifice scene
there's definitely an underlying theme
here in relation to the Romantic tension
between the two need's weapon of choice
is a box cutter you know what this is
for ah huh it's for cutting boxes it
took me a while to figure out what the
meaning of this line was but I think it
calls back to a mostly forgotten slang
term from the 2000s where female
genitals were sometimes referred to as
the box so by threatening to cut the box
needi is symbolically moving on from her
feelings towards her bfx there's also
the fact that the two used to play in
the sandbox together since their
childhood sandbox Love Never Dies
Jennifer levitates both of them into the
air but the deciding factor is when
needi pulls off her BFF necklace symbol
Al cutting the ties of loyalty that she
has to her abusive friend and this sends
her crashing down to the mattress where
needi finishes it by jamming the box
cutter into her ex-best friend's heart
as the library books for told demons are
weakest when hungry but a blade to the
heart is the shest way to kill the Beast
my T
no your heart it's one last joke in a
story filled with funny Cliffs but it's
also the Perfect final moment for
Jennifer as needi put it early on tits
were her trademark they were what she
used to get what she wanted at the the
bar and get what she wanted from the
boys in her class but relying on a
superficial Beauty signifier prevented
her from forming any real deep
heart-to-heart connections Diablo Cody
actually credits this as her favorite
line in the film and what happens next
really drives home the main idea
Jennifer's mom hears the commotion and
comes into the room to find NY pulling
the box cutter out of her daughter it's
the first time that we see Mrs C and
it's a reminder that after everything
Jennifer was just a kid or at least a
teen who was trying to grow up too fast
and got burned by a group of rockers
trying to use her needy dropped the box
cutter on this flag team magazine again
something only a teenager would have
through it all Jennifer was a victim as
well as a villain she didn't ask to be
turned into a succubus and all of the
strange behavior that followed
represents her going through the changes
that come with puberty and adulthood but
because she's not ready for any of that
she doesn't handle it well at all you
could say that her maturity was stunted
that day when L shoulder took advantage
of her something that we've talked about
before when discussing victims of trauma
on Horror history abuse neglect exposure
to violence lack of attachment and other
adverse childhood experiences affect the
structure and chemistry of the brain and
can stunt its natural growth and
maturation these negative experiences
have an effect not only in childhood but
throughout life adult relationships
grief and the dissolution of childhood
friendships are just a few of the
challenges that she does a very poor job
of coping with that's my analysis of the
character and I pretty much know that it
is correct not only because screenwriter
Diablo Cody and I are practically the
same person but because she's actually
spoken about the themes of Jennifer's
Body in interviews the theme of
Jennifer's Body said Co is about the
horror of being a teenager a person who
is under the influence of hormones and
jealousy in society is by nature
combustible and scary and unpredictable
and I think anyone who's ever lived with
a teenager knows this to be true and
Jennifer herself is in a special kind of
hell where her selfworth completely
revolves around her sexuality and who
she is as a body or a package so that's
how we began the movie and this is also
kind of a recurring theme for Cody whose
previous film Juno also deals with a
character who is forced to grow up too
quickly a girl who gets pregnant at age
16 Juno uses the same same kind of
imagery that Jennifer's Body does to
highlight the contrast between the young
girl at the center of the story and the
Very adult decisions that she's forced
to make like the call with the abortion
clinic on this hamburger phone that
looks like a toy they even both have the
same grading classmate God appreciates
your Miracle Low Shoulder are American
Heroes even though Juno takes place in a
realistic World there are still a lot of
similarities it seems likely that this
recurring idea of the teenage girl
forced into the adult world is a
personal one for Cody who sees needy Les
Nikki as a representation of herself
what I was really basing it on was
myself because I was going through this
transition in my own life I really am in
real life I'm a needy okay like I'm a
bookish insecure cowardly person and my
real name is Brooke and I had created
this Diablo Cody Persona to survive and
to get attention which is something that
I desperately needed at that time in my
life cuz nobody ever listened to me
suddenly for the very first time in my
life people were interested it was
definitely like a sort of
autobiographical for me writing that
movie was Jennifer then the projection
of your your Alter Ego then
and Jennifer were Brook and Diablo
exactly after releasing Jennifer's Body
Diablo decided to step away from public
life she got pregnant a month later and
focused her efforts on being a mother
the moment where needy plunges that box
cutter through Jennifer che's heart
symbolized Brook morio killing off her
flashier attention-seeking Alter Ego
Diablo Cody she stopped going to red
carpets and she took a break from being
on the internet to this day she has no
presence on social media which means one
of you will have to put this video on a
Blu-ray and mail it to her but even
though people in her personal life have
gotten used to calling her Brook again
she still continued to release content
under the name Diablo Cody it would seem
that the alter ego survived in at least
one small way does this mean that
Jennifer chech survived too that she's
been living in the shadows waiting to
make her return maybe in a 2023
interview the writer stated I'm obsessed
with the idea of doing something new in
the world of Jennifer's Body so we'd
have to go back to Devil's Kettle
Minnesota for that I originally planned
to pitch it as TV but I think it's
shaping up to be a movie we'll see yeah
Diablo if you're currently watching this
on a blue blay that someone sent you in
the mail please make it a movie and not
TV it's interesting how she says it's
something in the world of Jennifer's
Body it leaves open a lot of
possibilities perhaps some demonic power
keeps Jennifer alive or brings her back
to life but maybe she's only being kept
alive in spirit through her former
friend after she's killed in Jennifer's
Body we learn that nidi inherited some
of her powers most ult Scholars don't
know this but if you're bitten by a
demon and you live you just might absorb
some of the Demon's abilities for needi
seems to include levitation and super
strength but for Brook morio moving to
Minnesota and Reinventing herself as
Diablo Cody was necessary for her to
break out of her bubble and take a step
forward professionally she no longer
feels the need to use that name in her
personal life but still occasionally
calls upon that Alter Ego Jennifer's
Body has become a cult classic in the
horror Community but it's just one of
the greater coming of Rage genre for the
full picture you'll need to check out my
other coming of Rage analyses like my
video on Carrie you can find those in
the playlist on the left remember to
subscribe to C's worlds for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both
survive